he takes on a much more serious role in
the new CBS drama welcome to the CBS
family Jeremy call wisdom of the crowd
Piven plays Jeffrey Tanner a wealthy
tech entrepreneur torn to pieces over
his daughter's murder
he believes the wrong man went to prison
so he invents a real-time crowdsourcing
application called Sophie to help find
her killer
the high-stakes atmosphere affects
everybody involved including his
coworkers Jeremy Piven joins us at the
table hello Jeremy women the premise of
the show I think is fascinating he's a
grieving father he gives up his company
and offers a 100 million hundred million
dollar reward to anybody out there who
can help find his daughter's killer so
you're really engaging the crowd
instantly
yeah hero III I think he is but but I do
believe that he's an antihero because
he's a guy you know when doing my
research because I am a caveman with
technology and in reading about Steve
Jobs when he knew he had a finite amount
of time he became spiritual and I think
when Jeffrey Tanner my character lost
his daughter he was such an ambitious
guy who was running a company not unlike
Reddit and then he decided you know what
mm-hmm
I'm gonna put everything into a
crowdsource crime-solving sites that of
figure out who killed the daughter and
nothing else matters in this life not
being number one making money making
money all of these distractions that us
as Americans you know have in our lives
and as a result of this crowdsourcing
there's all these other crimes that end
up being solved right which is part of
the storyline yeah it is and that's the
procedural aspect of it and I think I
think both my character and I resist
that a little bit and I think what's
they resist it quite a lot
not a little bit yeah yeah yeah indeed
I I think that you know think that
that's an interesting duality in the way
that he's singularly focused on figuring
out who killed his daughter and he and
maybe a little selfish in that way but
you're gonna see that he realizes that
people want to do something good in this
life and it's inspiring to him these are
some of subjects is there comedy you I
hope so I hope so
that's you know that's the fun that
we've been having with it all is finding
finding that balance and Ted Humphries
who is the creator of the show is is
brilliant and also very collaborative
and we're all finding our way as a as a
cast and so we are we are going for our
laughs it's nice so were you trying to
find something that's the total opposite
of our ego listen you played it so well
that people actually thought you were
rich white obnoxious bitter they took no
prisoners that's how well you played the
role yes
well was that hard for you to deal with
Jeremy people would meet you and expect
you to be him yeah yeah I think you know
any actor that rails against the
universe for being typecast is you know
is you there's a long line to get into
yeah but I think if you embrace your
characters the first thing you do is an
actors you don't judge your character in
any way shape or form you can't because
if you judge them you're not going to be
giving them as much possible depth or
Integrity's as they can because no one's
a devil in their own story right yeah so
you know you know I do I had the same
ideology is Ari Gold did know I'm a
stage actor from Chicago I'm not a guy
whose parents were in theater - yes
indeed
indeed and we all know the real Ari and
he is an authentic yes prolific
character he is one of a kind you talk
to him about the character well I mean
he was my agent so you know the exact
back in the day so so yeah I got to I
got to witness it and so it yeah yeah
that was he was the muse definitely for
that character and and and Geoffrey
tanner who I'm playing now who it's you
know as a nice segue wasn't it sorry
doesn't dislike his character just
saying no no the real Ari doesn't
dislike his character right and yeah
that's a whole that's all but - now play
someone who was so incredibly human and
he's broken and he he hasn't dealt with
his grief and I think um it's it's it's
it's such a fertile premise for a show
and for a character that I'm loving it
and I think someone that's that driven
by his grief and obsessed with finding
the killer because he thinks it'll
soothe his grief and and that's not the
case it's very well done I want to go
back to choice question about your
acting family background but you say
even with the genes that you have your
DNA acting wasn't a foregone conclusion
for you but I think you know it wasn't I
I was lucky enough to grow up in the
Piven theatre and you know on stage with
my family and I was butchering check-off
at a very early age and and having a
blast but I didn't think it would lead
to anything because when you're in
Chicago you just don't think that you
could ever be on television or the
movies or anything like that and I
thought I was going to be a five foot
nine Jewish linebacker and that never
happened I don't think that rarely
happens in his life so I was delusional
beautifully I think delusional in the
way that I was onstage and improvising
and doing these great pieces but not
thinking it was gonna go anywhere so it
wasn't putting pressure on myself and
there was no desperation well you didn't
turn out to be a five foot nine Jewish
linebacker but it's worked out okay for
you Jeremy Piven really well we are
cheering you on here at CBS thank you so
much exactly yes family you can watch
wisdom of the crowd Sunday nights at
8:00 7:00 central right here on CBS yeah